now I just had a colonoscopy I'm sorry  yeah no it's fine I actually enjoyed it  I did I did enjoy it it was really easy  it's interesting  um it was really fun they made it really  fun really and just for all the creeps  and listeners out there I'd like to  introduce what we're doing today which  is  um we are getting our blood drawn for  these tests that were we were talking  about to compare all of our numbers I  think we should watch the needle go and  I have a weird thing I don't like the  little guy  I enjoy this is very strange I if I see  it on a movie or a television show I  have to look away but I enjoy watching  the needle go into my own that's funny  yeah I don't like it either throw it in  your arm and up your butt you're like  you just like to be broke yeah yeah you  like to be friends  he's enjoying this and I can't enjoy it  yeah  [Music]